a guy that charges very much would like
to have on the football field looks like
he's not going to be available this
season we said yesterday that derwen
james would miss significant time with a
torn meniscus and remember we said
there's two ways you can do the meniscus
you can do the quick fix
that that takes away cartilage that may
come in handy later in your career or
you can do the full repair that takes a
lot longer to heal it sounds like that's
what he's doing because it's six to
eight months per multiple reports that
he'll be out how big of a deal is this
for the chargers defense chris well i
don't think it's like a a deal breaker
let's just say that the chargers defense
is too talented to just have one player
affect them and do they just fall off
earth you know other thing is i'll say
that this they've done a great job tom
telesco gus bradley everything like that
realizing that this is a pretty
important position on their football
team so they have a few guys there that
yes no one's going to be derwin james i
mean other than jamal adams there's
nobody comparable to him in football
this is unfortunate but i do think they
can survive it certainly not going to
have him out there which is he's the
ultimate awesome guy i mean he really is
he can take on blockers he can fill a
hole and tackle a running back he can
run down the field and cover top-notch
receivers and tight ends like it's
nothing so they lose some of that
versatility and his talent there at that
spot but i still think this is a very
talented defense and they won't have a
problem i just feel bad for derwin james
i really do and i'm glad he needs to do
the right surgery don't do the quick fix
this is guys got a little bit of a he
had a knee history coming out of florida
state you got a long career ahead of you
don't just you know tape and staple a
few big things back together here uh i
think this is the best move for the
long-term future of his career and chris
we talked about this yesterday as it
relates to the eagles as it relates to a
team that has constant non-stop injuries
when it's a player who gets this
this label right at at what point is it
i know derwyn james just isn't built to
be an nfl player he's got the skills
right but the body isn't able to handle
the traumas that will happen to it from
time to time the foot has an issue the
knee has an issue this has an issue it
almost reminds me of bob sanders yeah
when you can finally get bob sanders
healthy and on the football field he was
the best defensive back in football the
best safety at least and he fueled a
championship run for the colts in 2006
right
but you couldn't keep him on the field
right in part because he threw his body
in that harm's way he welcomed it
didn't understand the connection between
doing that and maybe getting injured
right but i i you know maybe that's the
way derwent james plays maybe he plays
with that same kind of abandon and and
you know he's he's not going to how how
how do you value him after his third nfl
season and give him a big money contract
if he's going to miss all of the year it
pushes everything back a season now for
him and for his career and and he's got
to establish he can stay healthy before
the chargers make a huge commitment i i
agree you're right i mean you know
whether we like it or not and how much
we like him as a player and gosh i like
him as a person too
yeah the label is gonna be here to it's
gonna stick now he he is he's gonna have
the injury labeled next to him until he
can prove he can you know clump together
a few seasons in a row without getting
hurt or something like that but you're
right it's gonna hurt his you know
ability to ask for a new contract and
you know it's it's interesting what you
bring up with the bob sanders and things
like that too you know bob sanders was a
smaller guy who was really thick and
stout derwin james you know he's a long
wiry guy which doesn't always mean
you're made to be you know in the mosh
pit and take on blocks and you know deal
with the intensity and weight of those
some of those collisions that go inside
the tackle box there that's where he's
rare because you know he can do that but
yet he could get on the edge of a
defense and run down lamar jackson if
you watch him in college or watch him in
the pros as rookie year do stuff like
that that's where it's unique but you
know maybe that maybe that is something
we're going to watch for here maybe you
know that's something he's gonna have to
improve about his physical ability
become a little thicker and stronger
maybe compromise a hair speed for that
so he can take the wear and tear of the
job
well it's definitely an issue for him
and it's an issue for the chargers and
now there's an issue as it relates to
replacing derwyn james here's part of
the press availability from monday with
chargers head coach anthony lin on the
question of whether one fairly
recognizable name may be added to the
fold in la
a week ago a couple weeks ago you
mentioned that you know you guys weren't
inquiring about earl thomas um has that
changed at all he's obviously a guy that
knows your defensive system pretty well
well we have a lot of guys here in this
camp that knows our system really well
you know since you guys are consistently
telling me how stacked we are in the
secondary why the hell would i be
looking anywhere else
well that's anthony lynn
putting that issue to bed quickly hey
you're telling me how great we are we
don't need anybody else so it looks like
no home
for uh earl thomas in la and and
you know
we're a week and a half removed from all
the stuff that went down for the ravens
and earl thomas and earl thomas not even
a sniff i'm telling you just wait just
wait till he ends up playing for the
patriots for for the veteran minimum
just wait well i mean we'll see i will
never you know i'll never you're right
that would not shock me um i know this
you know again
and it doesn't like earl thomas he's
still a starting caliber safety in
football but i need to address this
because like i people with my social
media last week i mean
just non-stop on me because i said earl
thomas was a middle of the pack safety
listen everybody that added me on
twitter and all that you're wrong so
shut it if he was a top five or a top 10
safety he'd be on a team right now it
would have already happened his laundry
list of off the field issues are not
that long he's not a top five or top 10
safety i know he's earl thomas he's
going to the hall of fame
chris you're overlooking one very
important i understand no no no all 32
teams are wrong and the people on
twitter are right
you're right you're right i know i know
you're probably and i'm i'm the biggest
fool on tv that's that's right that's
what i do well you're right there
yeah you'll agree with them
experience
there is something to be said about that
all right uh so the charges have to go
forward without during james and we feel
bad for doran james and uh you know it's
and here you know it happens every year
key player big name gets injured and the
train keeps rolling
and it's out of sight out of mind just
like ben rothersberger last year cam
newton last year it's going to happen
and this is the first big name
at least big name from the perspective
of people who pay close attention not
necessarily a household name as far as
football fans go but darwin james out
for the year
not good obviously especially because it
felt like this was the year he was
really going to establish himself
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports